right taste my Mo's film site is Justice
League legend waiting for Justice League
it was X Friday and this is a DC Comics
Code the super group and this your first
could real go at being Aquaman we have
sort of seen you yeah we know we haven't
so it's they're all there there's the
flash Wonder Woman Batman cyborg and you
Aquaman
and why why act man why have you all
been joined together in this way the
world as we know it is gonna end no yes
just I hate to break the news to my
friends kind of save you obviously you
know in terms of the superpowers cuz
obviously all superheroes you've got
super powers so command water-based
could breathe onto water presumably yes
but what else can he do he can command
the ocean so he can you know I basically
talk to fish if you wanted me to I don't
know make you sushi I can do that like
put the plant
Jonestown for fish super-strength and
and you've got your hang on it's a
squint kwinda agent Quinton it's not the
Trident yeah we don't get to try it into
a little bit later next movie so I think
the Quinn don't you step back there you
this is this real good reaction to a for
well done
this one's a nice light one oh I see I
could do that I do break a lot of these
okay I mean I do break a lot of them but
[Applause]
[Music]